[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que ton rite veut libérer
avec le délinquant
Ceci et Barabbas
un tueur qui mérite 10 fois le prix
décès
et c'est le Nazaréen
libère ton bienfaiteur
[Musique]
pauvre Nazaréen mais ce lavage de la mienne
je te témoigne aussi
je ne suis pas ton complice
par Sur Espagnol Sur American Girl
des détails
mettapiositi doit applaudir Palais
régional à non Arbres thefor De Palma
à Trapani
demoiselles les querelles confèrent préparé
Visites
[Musique]
visiter Marsala c'est assister aux traditions
D'abord et avant tout, la principale raison est que
Je crois en Dieu et c'est donc la raison
fondamental qui m'amène à participer
lors des deux événements et ensuite sans
le doute est une représentation même
toucher et puis un très grand
tradition pour la ville de Marsala qui
la procession dure depuis des centaines d'années
existe et donc c'est bien que je
les garçons marsal participent à cela
manifestation pour continuer
notre tradition
[Applaudissements]
alors peut-être que sans se chevaucher ça commence
un et puis tout le monde y va
ensemble
de la passion de Jésus
Cristèl sur les effets
[Musique]
et le premier ministre représente parmi les ne sait
que les représentations
vidéaste Moses Bianchi ou le théâtre
ni le relâchement du crunch assis
[Musique]
pardonner
des idées
[Musique]
tu passeras pour toujours seul
le péché d'esclave vous êtes des réseaux
mosciante exclusive et si oui dans le travail
[Musique]
de la région alors qu'elle n'en a pas
tout Sam
si tu fais
Au revoir les gens qui ils sont
Je ne sais pas
set seps et pas avec fa aussi
tradition
Les filles siciliennes sont religieuses, nous me désolons
seman la religiosité
Ce
paramètresnter de la religiosité de
la naturopathie
de la procession à Piazzale chausseur
pure religiosité factuelle
de ces gens et de ces pierres
et même si limoge Jean boucula religieux
par Betty's Girl
de Palerme Trapani
Catane et via l'arche de Pâques
si vous savez quelles sont les caractéristiques de San Biagio
était préparé
entre parenthèses
pour eux
odeur de canne
oui à nous une montettosa sur plastique
leur e è Tosato le prouve
bénévole
soixante-dix
[Musique]
pour les jours de fleurs
Plus
une tranche bluegracieusement
[Musique]
St
la passion et Gemma
ça part pour le plaisir dans Nose Puma a
sens satisfaisant
tuvefer parce que si ça fait tout le monde ça
ta maman est perdue c'est toujours comme ça
la semaine sainte le Sion Sicil
affirmer Chap particulari trésors
Pascal
présence et injustice dit si
pressant pas une fois moderne
de la fiscalité géographique trois
fondamentaux de la Méditerranée
Le christianisme a un 3
sur le béguin
pur la convivans de la présence latine et
de la présidence byzantine
Après vous
La Sicile est bisanthè de rith
bisandres de Constantinople
de la religion byzantine ce que je voulais
dis moi très simplement mais c'est ça
une église de rite grec byzantin
nous sommes catholiques nous l'avons toujours été
nous étions nos premiers pères
Albanie
l'actuelle Albanie Péloponnèse Et celle-ci
partie de l'Empire romain était sous la
juridiction du pape de Rome donc
nous étions déjà catholiques
Je prends l'affection de Ramù
à Piana degli Albanesi
ils se réunissent avec un prêtre
ils chantent comme avant
[Musique]
la tradition byzantine Fe seme moir de
Croix de Lazare
[Musique]
la chande du zaz De Lazzaro si le
aperçus de l'événement
de la résurrection du Christ
Comment il égalé par la personne
de l'azar
[Musique]
à la porte le si la représentation de la
Christ un
fehkappeler Lazare
[Musique]
la porte et si en retour le rappel est à 7
Avenue
[Applaudissements]
à bientôt Insigne de la tradition
religieux Universel le représentant le
V la fécondité
[Musique]
de la tradition byzantine albanaise
au lieu de la baguette de Lazare et lexame
des siens ouvre le voile Pascal
et boku de Jones Bienvenue
parler albanais à l'esprit rien Lang e
traditions religion j'ai un
part-tigiu en Albanie
[Musique]
si la mémoire du Tambour 3 à Jérusalem
avec Rua
à Piana degli Albanesi levec Mont sur e
je ne vous vois pas trois particuliers
s'il la représentait une plus ansienne
le serituel et si
erics car il n'a pas trouvé serituel a
Jérusalem ou Catherine Secret
de la tradition grecque byzantine
[Musique]
Piana degli Albanesi a soutenu si
ancien rituel et setter a un influenceur la
Tradition populaire sicilienne des Parsons
leville ou turde Piana de Provence de
Palerme et Agrigente de pret che montlan
je pense que si je clame la France de
planifier un rituel
la présence des fans si je suis présent
que si Fè parce que le logiciel
si c'est dans l'ouest de l'émission
si tradition si c'est différent d'un
tradition albanaise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant la signifie le sens de
procession qui a précédé le divin
liturgie de saint Jean Chrysostome
il veut être précisément l'entrée de Jésus
à Jérusalem pour moi c'est un grand
embarras de monter l'âne
et les 16 ans que je fais cette fonction
pour moi c'est un fait
dans lequel je me sens presque mal
je sympathise avec
personne du Seigneur je sens que j'ai
Christ dans mon coeur
[Musique]
La Liturgie de la Mère de la Messe à vous
avec tous les droits de Franken euh la
structure fondamentale que si le
liturgie de la parole la liturgie
eucharistique
la différence si les types d'expressions
les différences sont là au niveau de l'expression
au langage expressif me la structures
[Musique]
avec la conférence de crétienne moi
Minoritair de rith bisanthé particule
et de la Provence de Messine sur
montagne
[Musique]
sait qu'il a des fonctionnalités
Sicile
en progression continue de
Christianisme
[Musique]
mère
du confrère le lamentation
[Musique]
hypothèse
c'est un chant polyphonique
il y a la première voix et la deuxième voix
et le chœur répond
[Musique]
les confréries nous sommes six mais où
ils chantent Nous ne sommes que trois
fraternité de toutes les compétences qui
il y avait dans le mentor mais le seul pas
dire que je suis le seul
fraternité qui avait des dieux
les bons plaignants étaient là où je suis
en compagnie des leçons il y avait un
bien sûr grand ouvert est un certain loup
Mercredi je serai Ily a la procession qui
sort du gleeze que tu as conféré
sonsieur leg lisbarrassian
de la crèche pascal et après
[Musique]
des départs
Panda le cortège ilant
de l'amentation
il faut dire qui exprime la su France
aussi la passion du Christ et aussi l'amour
du Christ
une complainte représente Il y a de la passion
du Christ c'est-à-dire que nous représentons la mort
de Jésus
ça commence le dimanche des Rameaux
diverses lamentations sont exécutées
les têtes qui viennent enchanté le fils ou
sur la scène du spectacle gleeze
ou anitalia ou personnes âgées
tant ces lamentations parce que c'est tellement
vraiment commencé comme un gamin j'ai suivi
La fraternité où comme ces
fraternité et il y avait mon grand-père
mon père est toujours là
[Musique]
mais ensuite avec le passage du temps vu
qu'il y avait ces plaignants c'est moi
aimé j'ai vu que c'était une chose
intéressant et aussi à ne pas manquer
la tradition à Ali moins parce que si
En fait, nous, les jeunes, ne nous adaptons pas
ces belles traditions vont mourir
c'est-à-dire que je donne ma disponibilité
faire de leur mieux. Ce n'est pas ce qu'ils sont
un pic mais j'essaie de faire le mien
[Musique]
à Raffadali avec des formes traditionnelles
que si les hasards les lamentations les raisins
Je visite Merkel
[Musique]
quand on a le même genre de
paramètre lorsque nous avons
une personne décédée dans la maison et une visite est faite à
membres de la famille
comme s'ils étaient
ce moment
cela consiste
et se termine ce soir à 22h00
[Musique]
si lamentation à mer
En effet aucun Elie ne voile la tradition des lamentations
des Maisons
pour la visitation de paranchia pour Dieu dans
famille
[Musique]
Christianisme
retour à la place avec lenormann norman
ha Conche toile Sicile et les normands
offres en Politique de pénétration Latine
[Musique]
mon ensemble de dell'oriego una
fourrure pas fans si loriec tulies
la particularité
de la force de Grosse La Pre sans delle
théories exprimées par la tradition
byzanthée
au monastère brésilien les traditions
orientalsanten
fars qui est l'exactitude de Forza d'Agrò
aux monastères pour le déjeuner
[Musique]
si en cortège Qui est proche de
cérémonie de la consécration du Who is
Les lois du Père Noël viennent de la tradition
latent
benikwa e
la bénédiction toute la neige que vous
se glisser
d'affection orientale
[Musique]
à l'origine, Salò Deramo les avait
de l'est
de la tradition
grec oriental
grâce à l'action de grâce
banal oui c'est
de la procession et doit venir non
l'accent dans
harisme de
trois grands
la Présence du cristjepse que si elle a un
relation avec son
[Musique]
Signe Guardaset et 7 rapports
et la Consécration che illustris
par
[Musique]
la particularité de rancontra dei
prix si le pré sans UGL et le
décès
si dans langaj charnevallesk
Anselmour
manifestations à Casteltermini Fasano
du protagoniste Amadeus parce que le décor et
dans l'auto-mouvement Goku entre…
si je dans les expressions trois forces
avec le Terme della luten
Les problèmes
manifestations si la permanence de
Démonstration de charness
Mader a créé la manifestation qu'un roi a trouvée
et en grande importance thématique le
Sept versions de questions
[Musique]
les personnages emblématiques t'aimaient Port LARC
la soie signifiera que l'amour frapp-lom
et Lom Napa de chances
[Musique]
vous apportez les scènes et les scènes deviennent méchantes
que si le Mal qui entoure Lom et Scar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ouverture a nourri les rituels de la rancœur
trois significatifs trois symboliques
contrendler's ressuscitate essamè So le
diables est écrasé et écrasé
le diable et l'amour se prosternent
Essence de la Force et du Christ
Puis dans la soumission du diable et
de l'amour chrétien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
as-tu trouvé
Hé Google
[Musique]
L'expression
de la dramaturgie
à l'expression liturgique pars che la
semensant du liturgique
la mimesis
[Musique]
l'amp seed a la particularité
de la namnèse
savoir s'il est particulièrement explicite un
Jérusalem de
Euh la cretience
tu sais passer par la liturgie et le passé da
L'expression de la dramaturgie populaire
notamment
[Musique]
l'expression théâtrale anné down
à l'intérieur du Théâtre et à l'intérieur
delle Elise et je n'ai pas utilisé En effet oui le
présence de Tambour sacré tu sais que tu as
à l'origine de la tradition de
graine
la croix un peu comme elle deviendra un autel
avec ton geste beaucoup d'anxiété nervosité
stress et espérons qu'il fait beau
c'est assez
Je participe à la fois à la procession et à la
événement théâtral je veux dire la Foi
et puis pourquoi exactement
disons que le groupe des Apôtres était
toujours fait par les garçons par les étudiants
marsalesi de l'université de marsalesi e
donc vous l'achetez irrite ce serait le
groupe qui organise la procession a
pensé à ces chiffres pour pouvoir
représentent précisément les apôtres et les
Christ
à Marsala si celui qui participe au set
processions en F passe Purple Theatre
mais dans la dévotion
devoirs et responsabilités
de l'association il y a entré
[Musique]
il a participé au cortège des Messieurs
ex exprime si esfois la dévotion
par une période de pénitence
Marsala a un rituel et une procession
des mystères
il faut dire le métier de messieurs
vivant
de Professionnel
personnages Qui joue le rôle tu seaux pas
trouvé dans les collections des Evangiles Sulla
passion le Matt Assen tu Lemon de la
passion je ne suis plus aveugle mes yeux
Maintenant ils voient
7 expressions En effet oui le sapel Casazza e
si dans une expression que Selma n'a pas trouvée
entrer
les masques des figures du Christ le
je suis un coupeur
Qui porte le masque Il soda CAD vivant
les significations que si celui qui fait
Chris dans le protagoniste
parce que les protagonistes si Christ Alors
tandis que le masque signifie Donè vous
allaitant au caractère de
Christ mais vous ne comprenez pas avec la puissance de
libère-toi ou fais-toi crucifier
Ah oui oui il se caractérise par
une expression qui atteint la tranche
[Musique]
les fanfares moi ont utilisé les fanfares Chi son
de chansons
de michic de Gran tranche le Grand
[Musique]
de la procession de Marsala, il n'a pas trouvé
d'un Chapeau de véronique beauco de
jouer
avec deux enfants de la famille
et si j'ai une expression d'espagnol
Nouveaux trolls
o Iliade petitan fa chi vient Adige se
dans les ex-voto
[Musique]
l'ex voto qui s'exprime de Seth Roll à
démotivation boku
le rinçage repose sur Dieu pur varkel
Chaussures parce qu'il a des problèmes de maladies ou
autres issues
[Musique]
soi
longs métrages parle dramaturgie
expression théâtrale et expression
rituel
tu haite SAS à l'origine
la tradition de la Seine Saint Alex vous
les personnages de la passion et
l'amour du Christ et augmentez-le
la présence de
Qui représente
les différences
de la passion du Christ
[Musique]
La passion du Christ et la douceur du thé
monde
qui appartient au type de monsieur
si un professionnel
et les extrémités d'abord dans le désert
la selle disame Panda 3 mixte est une
visiter la villa si la manifestation de
De superbes tranches également de Trapani qui y vit
des relations
[Musique]
si dans une procession il caractérisait le
sociétés
choc monsieur appartient à l'incorporation
[Musique]
des différences
ils font
ils ont commandé et pris la Vie est
[Musique]
Porter si vous êtes une expression doner
la pénitence possède une expression de
ex voto fait aussi grossir Rachele
choc sur Kitty à la procession va pour
L'expérience de Surf France a une
référence à la liste
mais sauce au partage de la mode de
dévotion qui secoue qui se manifeste et vit
[Musique]
;
Je le trouve nécessaire à Trapani
en synchronisme
[Musique]
les personnages des mystères
si trois caractéristiques
Ensuite, vous manifestez dans Resistance Aran 3 le
poster le dialexé que le clan sait si
manifeste trefort avec
Clavière que si le Dernier
[Musique]
utiliser une représentation symbolique de
détachement scandiglia en or si le
manifestation de solitude
jepse qui donne le Retour tu SAS de Vien
la manifestation du surfacedutiste
[Musique]
à la fin du cortège
les différences
M. Panda Alan
[Musique]
dans la résolution de la manifestation avec le
fatigue moi ou Mental pur sere trouve
dos
[Applaudissements]
d'une manifestation de la psychologie
social
C'est donc un moment de libération
ce que vous vivez quand ça se termine
des 24 heures C'est une passion que tu es
rendu
14 ans déjà j'avais aussi commencé à partir de
petit
ton mystère beaucoup
particulier
il veut savoir quelque chose qu'il représente
pour toi cette participation celle-là
transformer les émotions
et autres leville et le village
notamment
et la différence si normal Pourquoi Nouveau
trouvées dans les villas et
une économie aux multiples facettes
il ne me voit plus
à Enna j'ai utilisé la manifestation trois
grand de la typologie du cortège
du Christ
la particularité d'une participation
énorme de la ville chi tulesome
appartient à boku De conféré
Emilia est un climat sérieux qui Reflex qui
sfeffe setadir est un enterrement de VTT
[Musique]
dans cette semaine pour ceux qui y croient beaucoup
avec son coeur il ne mange même pas de viande
vous mangez du poisson dans la carte d'extension
à la confrérie Santissimo Crocifisso
Dean, j'ai eu de gros problèmes avec
santé en 2003
et j'ai été
miraculeusement gracié par le Seigneur Tra
l'autre désir est d'aller
aussi à Lourdes en France
C'est donc un peu particulier pour
mon histoire personnelle
[Musique]
Comment jamais assisté
Confrérie du Très Saint Crucifix
de Pergusa vous êtes dans un village
Bref, en 2020
éclipser la seconde mi-temps
de la précision Enna la prouesse
cette participation ne vous devez apprendre dans
manifestation d'égocentrisme
del sefervoir moi les deux etern in
participation authentique à San Ettore
protagoniste Lumen
Ettore dei ceux qui expriment le gâteau participent
Chaussures qui si dévotion
tu connais l'ovni en l'achetant
du cortège
il règne une atmosphère de grand silence
religieux et fremendicant le franzisk
Les dimanches
fondamental
[Musique]
et en effet Seal the est une caractérisation
trois étroits Hunter les pois
[Musique]
la tradition du précepte pascal a
Et toi
et la fonction
[Musique]
vous les crétins
un ethme de
crèche
contrôle 3 Quatre par incision
[Musique]
alors traîne quelque part aussi
J'ai peur qu'ils aillent analyser
rien rien
et les deux à Assoro jepse que je n'ai pas utilisé le
rescapés des baquets Drapeau d'Etel
s'il ne flagelle pas son expression 3
pénitentiels
le cortège d'Assoro à Monaco si le
la procession vous garde expression
plus sancien que les professions de Londres
éloigné car je n'ai pas utilisé la Croix le
Crucifix j'ai utilisé l'éclairage de
Bougies crucifix traditionnelles va de
Lumières électriques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la caractérisation si que le Porter
ils crient ils ne chantent pas mais ils crient
Miséricorde
et tu sais tu es un vfe d'un différentiel
Vit à
[Applaudissements]
crie Miséricorde car si le mot
Central a donné ce cristofair
si de là ce n'est pas de la Miséricorde ce n'est pas
le pardon du pardon et de la rémission
des poissons et la via Ternana
tu sa passe dalla Misericordia
[Musique]
et les porteurs
d'une manière forte parce que d'une manière forte
participation d'une émotion forte
Donc
la manifestation que la femme s'est sentie exprimée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et les deux à Assoro il a la présence des dieux
les plaignants qui shant Lady Christi
faire pipi et exprimer des seaux et des marches
aux cristas
Puis il l'a trouvé à Assoro fit et je
dans la manifestation et une expression
Je voudrais mais puissant et si ça se conserve comment
nous avons utilisé à San Mauro à Castelverde de
une expression et trois Authentique de la
tradition du village de Foïs
[Musique]
si cela compte
et la présence des plaignants
en Sicile
tu as l'expression musicale
de la Passion et de la mort du Christ
Et puis on l'utilise all'angage ti pic
mais sicilien pas de frais de rituel
[Musique]
l'inquisition est une caractéristique
Latin
il est entré dans l'usage de l'église avec
Frederick II trois tante ensemble
la tradition des biens communs avec
surtout la périodisation
[Musique]
expression de graine
autres les problèmes que
sicilianecycle et je n'ai pas utilisé les trams
mondeters les plus sérieux
à 1 600
si le plus grave mais je n'ai pas utilisé le bokute si c'est le cas
phénoménal
si une expression de la nature
L'un est connu émotionnel
semaine du soleil
le chemin de l'espace
manifestation du saint
[Musique]
à San Fratello n'a pas sauvé la
particularité de la présence des Juifs
amis Alex salvadorn Professionnel ed
spécialiste du nord
[Musique]
garder à l'esprit dans un quart d'heure
Alors les vacances de Pâques sont vraiment des vacances
antique datant de la période de
Moyen-âge
C'est une tradition très ancienne et vous ne
peut comprendre exactement d'où il vient
Comment cette tradition a commencé
[Musique]
pour bien connaître la Tradition
de San Fratello tu dois avoir l'air différent
attends l'un est historique l'autre pour
l'environnemental et le troisième que le religieux
dans ces communes le se parle encore
coq italique il y a une langue francophone
une langue venant précisément de
Normandie et c'est la traversée de Long dock
ainsi que la langue qui était parlée dans
Espace transalpin
rien à voir avec les juifs car
Juifs dans notre langue d'Italie
vient de Judas parce que Judas s'appelle
Jurez au singulier au pluriel juré je
Ils veulent donc représenter le
la figure du traître va bien
avant, seul le cor était joué
a été annoncé la mort passionnelle de
Christ avec la corne
et à San Fratello il y a toujours eu celui-ci
grande disponibilité envers
les autres peuples n'ont jamais existé d'antisémitisme
Nous avons encore le grand honneur de
avoir le premier saint [ __ ] de l'église
Catholique moderne San Benedetto Del Moro
immédiatement après l'expulsion des Juifs 1492
commandé par Ferdinand le Catholique et par
Isabelle de Castille 90% Juifs
de Palerme Messine Catane et Syracuse lo
fui la Sicile si vous êtes
réfugiés et où sur les Arches des maisons
il y a l'étoile de david d'autres sont
réfugiés au nez de la province de Castroreale
de Messine où environ 1 700 familles
ils portaient des noms de famille juifs et étaient
vraiment juifs
et il y a eu l'inquisition à San Fratello
il y a eu l'inquisition à Mistretta le plus
féroce de tous était celui de Raccuja o
nous sommes chrétiens
que nous respectons et faisons Oui Juif
Ensuite, il y a les groupes organisés car
si vous ne vous organisez pas
répétitions à jouer dès la soirée
le matin il commence déjà à jouer
ils étaient autrefois utilisés, maintenant ils le sont moins
ça se lève
ils nous font ça
la blague est toujours faite
maintenant la jeunesse d'avant était plus pauvre
le pauvre juif en a fini avec
réconforte toutes les maisons tu manges tu bois
ça sonne Eh bien c'est toujours là
la tradition est respectée
en 1200 76
1276 fra Maniero Fasani de Pérouse fondée
La Fraternité de la Miséricorde
étaient ces jeunes qui oui
flagellé et qu'à l'occasion de
La semaine sainte vient d'avoir lieu
ce rôle au sein des églises
[Musique]
C'est jusqu'après le Concile de
Trent ces Juifs avec les autres
les acteurs sortent du domaine de
l'église et donc portant les vêtements qui
ils avaient leur propre costume romain
il y a toute une symbologie
Diabolique disons le fait qu'ils
par exemple, ils portent un masque
transposition d'autres événements
le masque est dû au fait que l'homme
qui porte la robe veut demander
le pardon des péchés qu'il a commis
en trois jours découvrez la Volt go
baiser les pieds du Christ
[Musique]
la trompette est nouvelle car avant la
ils en portaient un ou deux qui étaient les chefs de
ces juifs
immédiatement après la Première Guerre mondiale et
beaucoup de jeunes ont apporté des trompettes
militaire
[Musique]
la fête des Juifs et les trois jours avant
Mercredi de Pâques jeudi et vendredi
saint
et ces gens
à la maison on porte cette robe
tout décoré que vous devez le faire
l'argent et le temps que les gens dépensent
et tout fait à la main
le casque rappelle le type romain de
pantalon la couleur rouge est due à
fait que rouge à certains
populations et symbole de deuil
les broderies viennent plus tard car elles sont entières
une attribution qui au fil des ans a été
faites par les brodeuses de
Le style arabe et les revenus ne sont pas espagnols
toutes ces petites fleurs ne sont pas espagnoles
qui crachent du pantalon qui émergent
en vestes C'était une culture qui
il a été transféré par nous
[Musique]
En ce qui concerne la robe, il y a
autre chose à ajouter
exemple discipline cet outil
qui dans les temps anciens servait à battre le
poitrine aux épaules et maintenant à la place
il est transporté mais non utilisé
cette sorte
ceux de San Fratello ont trouvé un
grand personnage qu'était le Baron
l'arcane père de neuf enfants huit filles
et un mâle les huit femelles sont allées
tous mariés à huit princes siciliens
mais ce n'est pas le seul Baron de San
Frère l'a laissé entrer dit le
tradition locale fournie
pendant les trois jours du mercredi
Jeudi et vendredi saint portaient
la robe des Juifs Cela pourrait être
une version acceptable
et la femme de Don Giovanni d'Autriche
son frère naturel de Charles V était de
San Fratello et c'était une époque de largan
précisément la sœur du baron de San
Frère
temps du fascisme i
les carabiniers les fréquentaient à la campagne
et à la place ils se sont habillés le samedi
[Musique]
Les lois raciales de Mussolini en 1939
interdit par son propre décret que je
les jeunes du pays pouvaient porter
la robe jujube
la population s'est rebellée vers 90
jours où ils ont été arrêtés, ils ont fait 6
mois de confinement sur l'île de Lipari
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde ce qui se passe oui
commémore la mort de Jésus-Christ à St
Frère nous célébrons
Ok bien alors tu lui dis
Donc
j'ai eu la chance de le faire
passion vivante
et je n'avais pas à le faire mais je l'ai fait niveau
théâtral de
représenter le Christ dans une scène
théâtre en direct mais c'est très excitant
car et il faut aussi du courage
présenter le fixe pourquoi sur terre
il n'y a rien et égal à notre Seigneur
Jésus
[Musique]
les desserts sont aussi caractéristiques
caractéristique est le comportement du
église que tout en ne me laissant pas
Juifs à l'intérieur du temple cela de
dix ans maintenant au lieu de plus tôt
ils sont venus vivre en harmonie commune et en
d'un commun accord C'est donc le pays
de la Paix de la Foi des Traditions
et maintenant ils ne laissent plus entrer
parce que les prêtres ne veulent pas parce que je
Les Juifs sont les crucificateurs du Christ
pratiquement
le problème des juifs est un problème
délicieusement
notre territoire s'appelle les juifs
porteurs du Christ de Militello
Bon vendredi romarin et sont
quatre suffisent
l'expression rituelle de San Fratello sia
L'expression de la procession de la
Monsieur avec Deer
En effet Seal par mer et à travers
Coupeur Wikipédia Tip de procession
[Musique]
J'utiliserai le cortège de la Croix la
radio fin cortège Chris le
cortège de messieurs et mimesis à
Citron de la Passion et de l'amour di
Chris
la procession de San Fratello
appartient au type de
cortège de Mister if the Meme Shoes
ce que Trapani
il semble que non
J'ai utilisé la Croatie exemptée le crucifié
et la Vierge
[Musique]
la renaissance de Christ de
nous différons mais pour cela peut-être si l'un
professionnel qui appartient à
Monsieur
[Musique]
notre tradition
il continuera il défiera les âges parce que c'est un
tradition transmise de père en
fils
la robe du Juif est héritée de
père en fils viennent tout le temps
Tenues mises à jour avec revenus
neuf avec des choses précieuses
Merci merci merci
Merci beaucoup
[Musique]
Dans la période
baroques
Qui a Dona sous sa forme définitive
s expression vient de la tradition
le thé occidental de Gênes
expression artistique
le Sicil Panda plus les périodes modernes
tu as
tentant
provençal et espagnol
[Musique]
des processions des statues et au-delà
shosi
[Musique]
les survivants de la tradition
Signa Les prémices
Eh bien la fava leffeur
killzomi sur les statines
[Musique]
Je ne peux pas trouver 7 signes Oh oui des tablettes
du souper de la loi du Père Noël
Le
Lieu somptueux à l'agriculture ou je trouve
de la terre
[Musique]
ils sont particuliers Ah ils sont uniques au monde
et c'est une tradition
séculaire dans les années 1700 de ces Arches
parce qu'ils sont dans le signe
de la rencontre entre Jésus ressuscité et le
Madonna le jour de Pâques et bénie
c'est le fruit de tes entrailles Jésus
[Musique]
S'il te plaît
[Applaudissements]
nous ne reviendrons jamais
si le rituel
J'ai utilisé si grande expression que je ne trouve pas
par les singes de l'Arche qui se manifeste
à la fois un deguir de Trionfo il faut s'habituer
parce que Chris E ressuscite
puis j'ai vaincu les lavages de la mort
et le mans alors tu sais comment dire
traversée
dans une grande manifestation affective
San Biagio Platani
Qui sait si possible la vie se tient si le 7
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Comment se fait-il que le Christ et sa mère dansent et
pour la raison de faire la fête pourquoi pourquoi
Jésus-Christ est ressuscité et étant ressuscité
è Voici sa mère se réjouit Mais c'est un
fait un tel fait folklorique
ce n'est pas un fait biblique
[Applaudissements]
seule la lune sont les caractéristiques
de la nature bien le soleil qui est Jésus
Christ que nous sommes cette humanité Mais Jésus
Christ éclairé
quels sont ceux qui le caractérisent
nous avons remarqué qu'il y a un coq qui est là
l'agneau si je ne me trompe pas c'est-à-dire que je
Motifs de Pâques principalement l'agneau
et la colombe qui signe de paix
que sais-je la branche d'olivier Ce sont les
celles qui caractérisent principalement
les arcs de Pâques
ces décorations suivent certaines règles
précis pas extemporané ils changent de
année après année, cependant, ils n'ont pas de thème
principal
Comment ils viennent
mentionné par l'esprit du concepteur e
une fois qu'ils ont été faits et Via Crucis
à l'histoire de Moïse mais cette fois je
miracles de la mort de Jésus et puis un autre
temps et la résurrection du Seigneur afin
impromptu
Tant qu'il y a aussi des raisons
le printemps ou que sais-je de la beauté
de la Création Ici, ils louent la
beauté de la résurrection
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ni
culte personnel
[Musique]